lanza la spalla la espada giusto che hai
perfetto noi lanciamo alle spade voi non
lo sapete ma noi l'anziano io lancio
tool anzi egli egli è messa male
ragazzi siamo tornati certa troppo
tornano porto così non è anche i livelli
dopo che vissuta da un occhiata stavolta
fatto un cazzo cioè così a caso però la
mia gamba ha vinto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa sicuro ragazzina dei bottoni
reagan porca [ __ ] che cazzo fai chiuse
ha vinto ha vinto lui a caso mi spiegate
come ha fatto a rimanere in bilico sto
bambino sull'art
non è normale stai concerto va bene che
il suo motion facciamo perché da allora
li slow motion i ragazzi li devo capire
perché ok già fatta
l'utilità degli slow motion
io non l'ho ancora di giuro che non l'ho
ancora capito
facciamo due perché questo non l'ho
capito per niente perfetto che ti prendo
io ti prendo io ti salvo io ti salvo io
ve n'era quel che è che figo pregano
caso ecco perfetto no che rivelò figo è
questo no fermi un attimo ma che devo
fare
enter the box cioè io ho cliccato un
livello senza neanche sapere ma qualche
[ __ ] senza nemmeno sapere che cosa
stessi giocando a caso poi 4 niente non
so ragazzi non c'è oggi non c'è verso
non c'ho mischia piano merda si no la
madonna
[Musica]
questo è stato figo rega cioè non bello
incassi mi sapeva [ __ ] no raga non è
possibile
si no
mi sembra possibile una cosa musica io
non ho però non è poco non ci posso
credere
ma come fare sì bravo bello ovvio però
ogni oggetto di un cazzo non ho mai
visto una prestazione tanto ciò fatta
cielo formiche è stato impossibile basta
non ne voglio più sapere e super freeze
frame facciamo questo e mi sembra figo
sopraffini sarà bello siamo partiti bene
dicono come si destreggia una cosa non
come faccio assurdo e cosa fai
ecco forse farsi investire non è proprio
una mossa fantastica parte meno di
provare e riprovare ragazzi perché è
stato pazzesca la prima di esso livello
si bloccano i cubi e tu in cambio ci
devi dare le braccia semplice nostri
devo andare avanti porca [ __ ] che
testata level 4 una ragazzina fantastici
si riveli pro
però il mio pene ne risente fatte carico
ancora lui incredibile madonna ho fatto
è stato alla liuc l'abbiamo lasciato
indietro però sono ancora vivo posso
fare non è difficilissimo notato a meno
che i nomi sbrindella da solo però è un
altro discorso buono buono buono buono
buono come faccia passare quasi eccolo
ce lo fa ragazzi non è possibile come
fatta passava sotto
raga non ci posso credere la cosa più
assurda che sto tenendo il manubrio con
un braccio staccato e lo sto guidando è
bellissimo lo vedo troppo carico è di
oggi fermi un attimo che perfetto
non lo so il partito male l'ho visto
troppo caldo non so se bevuto qualcosa
di energetico prima ma è partito
malissimo ok ok grandi magari se portavi
dentro anche le braccia era meglio no
dove dov'è andato a finire il mio casco
che mi sabina
bella la puntura zio ascolta ed i no no
no massaggi alla schiena oggi non c'è
verso scocca bravi
ho fatto rob singh senza morire neanche
una volta un record mai successo in
passato il 99 perfetto oggi sono carico
anche di impossible al primo tentativo a
cannes al primo tentativo un cazzo
bas save yourself perfetto questa
immancabili [ __ ] devi morire no e
vacca gastro vivo sono ancora ragazzi
non si sa come ma sono ancora vivo
perfetto allora gli occhietti sente il
piccante cosa molto conosciuta no e come
tempo di questo che picca al punto
giusto però forse dovevo prenderlo un po
prima il piccante con il melone non l'ho
mai visto ragazzi però gli occhi glielo
devo dare perché eccolo la prossima
volta march prima no no perché il melone
mi piace ragazzi una cosa prelibate è
sentirei meloni questo è il masochismo
però è un non è una cosa normale prova
ben gente che sentirei meloni a caso
interno le angurie ho nemmeno un
probabile un partito marco fare qua dove
vi è una specie di corda celermente mi
sta tenendo io devo andare avanti lo
stesso non mi sta venendo niente però
faccio fatica
no ma porca [ __ ] non ci credo di un
maschio che non sogni a chi ti riferisci
zio però lo faccio per thrilling signa
logging ragazzi che lo sto facendo cioè
una è una specie di chi devo ammazzare
pieni non è perché ho ucciso non meno
sfigate questo ho ucciso non c'è anche
con una chioma certo cazzo non mancavano
sarebbe stata una mortifica uesto se
avessi preso è stata è stata una cosa
bellissima borrelli farlo ma no grazie
suono te lo facciamo solo che è meglio a
noi ma è un machete throw come cazzo e
se tutto quello ragazzi o stai bene
tutto a posto
no perché ti vedo malissimo prova beh io
c'è una mira che fa veramente pena come
può essere seduto così male
oddio no madonna ma che minaccio ragazzi
oggi nell ok per questo mi è morto
subito
se lo presto preso
che mira non si sa come ma sei seduto o
meglio di prima
credimi o di rob swing soul dire po di
rock bello mi devo aggrappare a della
gente giusta ma mi sembrano ora a ok
perfetto va bene ma [ __ ] si è
stato è stato impossibile ma ce l'ho
fatta
ho fatto ho fatto uno vinto va bene così
mario level da rollo del pollo giusto io
lo devo giocare perchè l'ha fatto rollo
de pollo rega non me ne frega niente
mori rollo del pollo sono io il più
forte qui non hai capito
l'altro ho smontato un bomba non so se è
normale anche anche le monete fantastico
devo andare perché cos'è giampà non vado
saltare che ci sono le bombe merda ce
l'ho fatta mio zio la rosa depongono non
mi avrai è stato pazzesco pazzesco come
di quella parte il fatto che chi è che
non mi sembra tanto mario ma più che un
livello arcade a caso perché tv si è
fatta in culo rollo decollo in culo il
mall of the dead c'è il flipper della
morte rega tipo devo andare bene ok
fantastici 9 fare questa cosa non lo so
ragazzi pro plan sto fermo qualche tanto
qua
però ero morto da un'ora e mezza ma ho
vinto perfetto magic sesto me cos'e
[Musica]
forse era meglio non scoprirlo playdry
dare a caso siamo regalati ci siamo ci
sia lo ridà strano che [ __ ] no noti
diritto va avanti doll uk bravo io mi
già sei un fenomeno regala la distratta
liu
sì però i tuoi piedi limine no ma guarda
che se i trojan dopotutto la accetta
adesso sono armato anch'io fantastico ma
si può
ci sono ci sono fuori stroia ce l'ho
fatta ho fatto ragazzo ci ho messo
un'ora ma ce l'ho fatta va bene così
calmo adesso no no ma prova che allora è
possibile riuscire a fare un pezzo
porca [ __ ] more more ok ok ok ok
calmi calmi calmi calmi calmi perfetto
prendono la rincorsa da d'acqua perfetto
value spinge si è fatta adesso non ce la
farò mai più ad andare avanti però fatto
almeno un livello l'ho fatto ok veloce
no no no no no no bravo dopotutto
stronzo abbiamo fatto anche a fare il
livello due ragazzi non si sa come ok
c'è jack sparrow ma mi capita che ci ho
fatto ho fatto la prima non ce la fa non
ce l'ho fatta a farne uno adesso ce la
faccio a farli tutti
com'è possibile che mi fa facendo
inciampare la scarpa grandissimo come
l'ho ucciso a caso non ho e non i cazzo
cazzo mi incazzo non c'è più collo ma
quella è una cosa parla
e stato bello devo grappa a prefetto la
macchina norma podda ragazzi mi sono
legato a lei fisicamente proprio rimb
questo questo mi piace è partito
benissimo perché è caduta nella
spazzatura cosa avete buttato quale io
non ho fatto un cazzo tratto io che lo
hanno martoriato di brutto è di non fish
c'è scritto da non puoi pescare di
quindi dammi una mano perché c'è una
trappola per orsi che che si mangia
l'aria o io non ho toccato niente non
perché quella gente sappia come l'ho
trovato delle gambe in compenso una
gamba
nessuna gambe ed ethernet ed ethernet
per che cazzo mi è caduto un bidone in
testa vabbè è rega yo yo quei bidoni ci
faccio amicizia è normale sta cosa ma il
pugno ma è alcuna padua shout ho fatto
un acrobazia mio dio capo ragazzi non so
come ho fatto a morire prima mano devo
assolutamente finirlo perché troppo figo
ok the big del sì ho vinto vito vinto
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere ma non
importa perché ho vinto la corda ragazzi
e santo è stato istruttivo però allo
stesso tempo e figo quindi non lo so
spiegare tutti ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto ma setacciato il commento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
lo divido tratta una descrizione se
volete un siero della giovinezza
pronuncia che facciamo una petizione
tutti quanti e glielo diamo
la smetto di sparare cazzate ok avete
capire che a me è più mi fa male mi fa
male psicologicamente quindi va andateci
piano
il video è piaciuto come al solito ha
lasciato un commento mi piace anche a
pagine di facebook e come noi video tra
tana descrizione cento se volessi
d'ischia temi ci vediamo al prossimo si
picchia sui [ __ ] che in tutti i
punti in cui poteva cadere proprio sulle
palle fantastico bella ragazza